[Music]
foreign
we're going to talk about
one thing that I think everyone will
find interesting it's like inside
baseball it's like behind the scenes of
the Pod what our current numbers are the
revenue we're making from it
and like how we grew it and things like
that and also yours as well because
you're earlier in your journey so that'd
be interesting to people we'll start
with Jonathan on here too who Jonathan's
our numbers was he knows all about
growth and how we grew it I'll do I'll
kind of say what the high level numbers
are for my first million and you could
do the same for your pod so I just
looked in megaphone that's the software
we use so this every number I'm gonna
say is the trailing 30-day numbers so
trailing 30 days for my first million
when we say the word downloads We mean
YouTube and also like podcast downloads
which is basically apple and Spotify and
then a much smaller percentage is like
Stitcher and all the other podcast stuff
and so for that
for the podcast downloads we did one
point uh Roundup 1.3 so 1.255 it looks
like million downloads on like the
podcasting platforms then our YouTube
page right now has a 110 or maybe 112
000 subscribers and then the trailing 30
days we did 2.7 million views of which a
lot are YouTube shorts so maybe in maybe
1 million to 1.5 million is actual
episode episode views which is like any
video that's more than like six or eight
minutes long something like that
previously not this past trailing days
but the one before that I think we are
at 3.6 million so we're down a little
bit but because we had a few shorts go
viral so
1.3 plus 2.7 that's 4 million so that's
about how many people saw our stuff and
then there's like
all the social stuff so my personal
socials have been viewed I just looked
this up over the trailing 30 days on
Tick Tock I think I have two or three
million views and then on Instagram I
have like another two or three million
views so that's like the total reach
right now what are you at for how to
take over the world
so right now monthlies are at about 70
000 uh sorry 80 000 downloads
um and then
my per episodes you know stuff that's
mature so like a good example Walt
Disney has been out uh since January
it's been out for a while and that's
hovering around that one's got 39
Alexander the Great has 43 so around 40
000 my biggest episode is uh now almost
uh it's 54.
um so like kind of 50 000-ish uh per
episode and my number is like obviously
the totals are way different and weird
because my volume is so much lower
um what's our volume what's my first
Millions volume well as you mentioned so
we're going three times per week
um
and then we've got the shorts on YouTube
and then we've got the clips on YouTube
which drives a lot of the volume as you
were mentioning uh my first Millions
downloads per episode that's the number
that matters most it ranges from like 50
000 to 150 000 right that's right
depending on if you include YouTube uh
because if you include YouTube we have
some that Pop
um
up to the like half million
um maybe a little less
um
but like the darn mesh episode did
really well the Peter levels episode did
really well and those have hundreds of
thousands of views just on YouTube alone
so what are you doing to grow for me the
big thing is just fixing my production
process which is totally broken for how
to take over the world it's it's really
just a volume uh
game at this point for me are you making
money from it I'm making a little bit of
money I'm at least I am making money
um I used to I was negative for a long
time and then I was neutral for a couple
months now I'm positive how much do you
charge for an ad about a thousand bucks
per per placement so everyone asked my
first million I get messages all the
time saying hey can we advertise on the
Pod so my first million I said we're
going to talk about how much revenue it
makes it makes zero Revenue because
HubSpot when they so the way the our
process worked with my first million was
uh the hustle owned my first million so
Sean actually came up with the idea and
he goes hey can I do uh I want to create
a podcast you guys want to be my
publisher and I said yeah but we're
going to own it and he said that's fine
um and so we did a revenue split I don't
remember what we did but I think we did
50 50. so let's say the hustle sold uh
ten thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars worth of ads the hustle uh gave
him 5 000 and we kept five thousand and
then we also paid for it which
I don't know if that's actually a good
deal for him or us I don't know but when
we sold the company HubSpot bought the
hustle and they bought the podcast with
it and now HubSpot is the only
Advertiser on the Pod but we don't make
any money from it so directly although
they can calculate how much money they
would make off of it if they had to go
and buy those ads elsewhere but I think
so I went and talked to a friend my
friend has a podcast in the health and
wellness space and I asked him how much
revenue do you guys do and so they get
seven million downloads a month and they
are currently doing three million in ads
5 million selling like uh programs like
fitness programs and then like another
half a million in like merch and
affiliate deals and so collectively
they're doing around 10 million in
Revenue with about 65 profit margin so
it's quite good and so I think that rpod
just off ads
would maybe be in the 6 million range so
it would be around
75 to 125 dollars per 1000 downloads and
that would be separated in like a bunch
of different thirty dollar per thousand
downloads ad so we could probably charge
25 to 40 dollars per ad and then you
have like two or three ads in the in
each podcast and that's how you get to
like that five or six million range then
another like
three or four million just off some like
courses or paid Community yeah and
that's not uh taking into account costs
because if we're selling our own ads
we'd probably have to get an ad guy to
actually sell it and he'd take a cut
correct uh and stuff like that yeah so
what's our cost now for for MFM Jonathan
do you know for production side you know
between we got Ben you know producer
we've got uh Ezra who does the video and
audio cutting uh video and audio editing
we have the short form Clips folks we
have our YouTube producer so between
that whole team it's like 25k and then a
month
yes and then if you include you know
other
ways to grow the show whether it's
buying ads on other podcasts other
platforms
um it could be anywhere between like 25k
a month to
upwards of like 50 to 100. just so like
our costs right now not including me and
Sean it's like uh 500 000 a year roughly
yeah
I mean and you can scale it up and down
it's just like we're being aggressive
with our growth goals so
we're putting a lot of investment into
that and our growth is basically you buy
ads on other people's podcasts and that
works decent it seems but actually hard
to track but that's decent and the other
thing you tried like buying ads on
YouTube channels and things like that
right do any of them actually work you
think we Ransom ads on YouTube and it
definitely drives like a lot of views
and some subs but it's not necessarily
sustainable and you always kind of
question the quality of those subs
um yeah I don't know we've kind of
tested everything in like the thing that
we're most bullish on is obviously the
short form Clips it's also not easy to
tell how well those are kind of
performing in terms of viewers and
listeners to like the RSS feed but um
you know that's just like a long-term
play and as you're seeing like your
growth on Instagram and Tick Tock is
um largely driven by these clips from
the show and so it's just like you're
not gonna maybe that viewer isn't gonna
convert the first time they see it the
second time they see it but hopefully by
the 50th time they see your face they're
like I just need to check out what
he's up to and check out the podcast
Ben are you doing anything to grow no
basically just working on more
production that's basically it
but like my organic growth has been huge
like honestly as long as I produce more
episodes like it's gonna keep growing
I've done a little strategic
uh like who I choose in order to grow a
little bit like what I cover and I think
probably with podcasting that's the
biggest driver of growth
and you are basically at how many so the
way that we found Ben was I was just
I was actually taking a flight at like 5
a.m and I was like exhausted and I was
like I need some inspiration and I think
I looked up like Napoleon or something
like that and I saw your pod and at the
time roughly how many downloads did you
have at that point monthly downloads
would have been in the like hundreds to
maybe low four digits and I was getting
like a couple thousand uh per episode
and then we mentioned you on the Pod and
is that like the thing that was like the
big up like we we did this like pretty
big thing about you or I was like Sean
this is like the greatest intro song and
pot I've ever heard of and how much did
that boost
so I've gone from 2K to like 40K and I
would say that it's been like half and
half so half of it was like a big
upswing like I immediately went up to
like 10 to 20 and then since then it's
been steady growth from 20 up to 40.
dude that's the thing about pods
everyone talks to me they're like I
wanna I wanna do this and I go just so
you know it's very very very hard to
grow so at the hustle we had maybe one
point between one and 1.5 million
subscribers when we launched this pod
and so Sean was like Hey I want to do
this thing I said all right great he
goes in fact I already have like a pilot
episode he sent it to me I was like oh
dude this is like great as is I'll give
you three weeks or four weeks to like
get like ahead of the game and then
we'll we're launch we'll launch one a
week and basically that first week we
launched I think that first episode got
50 or 60 000 downloads
the next episode got like 30 or 40 and
then it just like ticked down until it
was like five to fifteen thousand
downloads per episode because we blasted
it to the hustle got traction and this
is how all pods and maybe maybe like all
not all but many products work your
launch is like epic then you go down and
then you just over a period of a couple
years work slowly work your way up and
then one day someone didn't appear to
one of his uh
to one of his uh like one of his guests
didn't show up and he was like Hey you
know how we do that thing so me and Sean
used to meet like every two weeks and we
were just like brainstorm in front of a
bunch of people and be like you know the
thing that we do uh can you show up in
like an hour and just come do it with me
the person didn't show up and I was like
I guess and the results were like decent
enough that we're like all right I guess
we'll just make this the thing and we'll
just keep trying and from there it
slowly went up and when we got acquired
we had acquired in February of like 18
months ago I think we are doing
600 000 downloads per month and then it
like went up from there a lot and I
don't actually don't know why it went up
I don't know what happened that's
interesting uh so like the idea for what
my first million became was basically an
accident is that right yeah so it was
like first of all I didn't want to do a
pod forever I thought it was a total
waste of time I was like we have to
focus and he was like I have this thing
and basically Sean at the time was not a
Content person he is now and he's great
but at the time he was just like uh my
friend who just like was you know he
wasn't on I don't even think he was on
Twitter he's a startup guy he's more of
an operator he would yeah yeah yeah he
was just he was just my buddy who had a
company in the gaming space and
obviously he was always charismatic and
he was pretty good at storytelling
although I would say that's even
improved a significant amount but he was
like I just interviewed my our buddy
Sully here just here's the pilot and I
heard it I was like oh dude this is this
is baller this is awesome it wasn't
actually that different than anything
else it was called my first million
because he was going to talk about how
people got their million users or
revenue or profit whatever and it was
all about the early days but which
frankly isn't that unique but he was
pretty good at it and then like six
months in or three months in someone
didn't show up and he was like hey come
do this and me and Sean loved this
podcast called The Fighter and the kid
and it was Brian Callan and Brennan chop
two guys sitting on chairs just like
goofing around and we're like oh that I
think we could do that and so uh we just
kept doing it like that's interesting to
me because a little bit when I started
my podcast it was the same thing of just
that it was kind of an accident I was
sitting there I had been reading this
Napoleon biography and I thought I want
to remember this like I want to retain
more of this information I should create
something I should make like a blog post
uh or uh a a tweet storm or something
and then I had all this audio equipment
lying around I thought I'll just do a
podcast about it
um and I bet people would like to hear
what I learned from reading this
biography of Napoleon and I think a lot
of really good podcasts start that way
of is not someone sitting down and like
gaming the system of like all right
where's a niche that I want to make a
podcast where's a niche but people who
are just kind of doing stuff and uh and
then it turns into a podcast and become
successful do you think that's right
maybe I think you could like I think
there are worlds like I heart media does
this nicely I think parcast which is a
podcasting company does this nicely
gimlet media does this nicely who else
does this
um
there's a wondery does a decent job some
are still better than others but
basically where they come up with ideas
and then they launch them almost like a
movie where it's like planned and
hopefully successful and then other
times it's organic I think the the
problem with podcasts there's a bunch of
upside I'll talk about the upside in a
second but here's the problem the
problem with podcasts is the same
problem that I have with copywriting and
hiring writers which is everyone can
talk and everyone a lot of people like
talking with their friends therefore the
noise to Signal ratio of people who want
to do it versus who are good at doing it
is like really really hard to determine
who's like great and so you have a ton
of people launching podcasts that are a
they're not committed to like the long
term like they're not committed to
making this and treating it like a job
or you you know me and Sean we were we
record every single Monday and Wednesday
and less of an emergency
um so they're not committed to that b
they're not actually good at they don't
actually have the skill or the talent
and they think they do because they talk
with with their friends a lot and so
there's like a lot of crap out there and
see it's not really like well thought
out where it's like you know Sean and I
joke we're like you need some attributes
man like you either have to have this
like crazy like interesting Niche or and
I would say this is definitely in Sean's
case slightly in my case you just have
to be really charismatic and good at
storytelling or you have to have like
some crazy experience so like you're
just an expert in X Y and Z or like you
know you're in the NBA for 20 years so
you can talk about like what it was like
being in the NBA like you have to have
something that's intriguing and a weird
angle or you have to be super talented
like a Malcolm Gladwell or something
like that do you know what I mean yeah
so what you've touched on something that
there's this guy Eric Newsom who's his
background is in public radio and then
he was kind of one of the ogs of
podcasting and he's got this framework
that I love for creating a hit podcast
so he calls it a diamond but there's
really four attributes on which you can
be unique and you need to be unique on
at least well really two of them in
order to be a successful hit podcast so
the four ways you can be unique are what
the podcast is about
who hosts it
who it's for
or the way you tell the story okay so
it's who so it's how it's told what it's
about who it's for or who it's by okay
so basically like the concept or the
person exactly and most people only do
one and that's where they fail they're
like oh I'm gonna make a podcast about
gorillas because there are no podcasts
about gorillas and it's like well are
you Jane Goodall like are you an expert
you need that second thing
um to make it successful and you maybe
you don't have to be the expert but if
you're not the expert then it's like uh
then you have to differentiate in terms
of how you tell the story you have to
give a really high production value or
uh you know you mean to like have
gorillas on the podcast or something
like that like you but most people are
just think of one new idea and stop
there whereas I think my first million
is successful because a
what it's about is unique in that it's
kind of an entrepreneurship podcast that
covers everything from like little side
hustles all the way to like big you know
Tech ideas that could be you know
hundreds of billions of dollars so it's
Unique on what it's about it covers
everything and then the the who you and
Sean have the experience and are really
funny and super engaging and it's like
it's like the all-in Pod like people
talk about that and I'm like you know I
think that they're like pretty okay
hosts themselves I think Jason's pretty
great but like you're gonna listen to
anything that they say because they are
so successful their world view is so
much grander than mine and you know
they're hanging out with like
ex-presidents CEOs of you know Fortune
500 companies like they've built billion
dollar companies like they have access
to things that I don't therefore they
don't even need to be and I'm not saying
they're not charismatic but I'm saying
they don't even need to be that
charismatic in order for it to be
awesome right exactly they have that
second angle the second angle doesn't
have to be that you're a great
Entertainer but you could have very
unique insights like those guys do but
you got to have something for that
second angle
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated whoa I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
but let's talk about the upside so the
the upsides to a pod is I have never exp
I don't I'm not popular I mean I'm
somewhat popular on social media but I'm
not like that popular on the video or
picture based social medias and so I've
not experienced what it's like to have
fandom there but for our pod the
benefits of having a podcast and I
noticed this to myself I'll listen to
other people is
I truly become like fans of these people
because I get to know them so well and
that is like a huge benefit and so like
I'll mention like sometimes people will
come up to me and they'll say yeah like
I'm I eat this food because you talk
about her I read this book and I'm like
I don't even remember mentioning that
like I just said I talk so much that
like I don't even remember all of it but
people like listen so much that they get
to know you and it's like creates true
fandom I think you probably could get
that at other uh platforms but I think
it's more so this because if they're 30
to 60 Minutes long they really get to
know you and also the the hard part
though is
you know the best way to circumvent
someone's detector
is just not bullshitting and that's the
hard part about that's the hard part
about about podcasting is when you talk
for 45 minutes or an hour and a half
five or three days a week or whatever it
is
you you ha you can't lie a lot you can't
lie at all because it's gonna catch up
to you you have to be authentic you have
to or if you're gonna play a character
you gotta play that all the time I mean
like you really have to be authentic
the the greatest thing and the worst
thing about podcasting is such an
intimate medium like you're in someone's
ears they're doing when they're doing
the dishes when they're commuting
um they feel like they're friends with
you I think more so than
YouTube Instagram like any other media
format TV whatever people really feel
like they have this relationship with
you which is a little weird and like
as you alluded to I think the most
difficult thing about podcasting is that
it's really difficult
it's like hand-to-hand combat to build a
big audience but the best thing about it
the best thing about podcasting is that
you can build
uh a really valuable following with very
few followers if you have 35 000
followers on YouTube
you just can't do much like you're
nothing and I talked with someone the
other day who has 35 000 downloads per
episode on his podcast and is making a
half a million dollars a year from it
and uh genre or category productivity
yeah all right so 35 000 downloads an
episode and he's doing half a million in
ad Revenue yeah
and then she could be doing way more off
like courses or whatever else she wants
to sell he could be doing three or four
times as much as that yeah and he's
talking about doing that stuff he's not
doing it yet so like I don't even feel
like that's
the limit of what you could do with that
many followers
so
um I do think that's the beauty of
podcasting is if you can like grind it
out to get a decent following of a few
tens of thousands you can make like real
money in podcasting yeah and the best
way I think you do it is if you already
have a business so for example I didn't
know this but you know that guy Patrick
David Betts I think his name is he's got
that YouTube channel called
valuetainment so I just thought that he
was like a personality and he recently
had a life insurance I think it is the
company that he sold for like 300
million dollars and I didn't even know
about that and that's way more valuable
than I mean his YouTube channel is very
valuable but not two or three hundred
million dollar valuable same with Dave
Ramsey Dave Ramsey I was researching him
his company's worth something like seven
or eight hundred million bucks and it's
a collection of real estate and selling
like personal finance stuff and the
radio show is definitely awesome but
it's not it it alone ain't worth that
it's not the monetization engine and so
if you already have that monetization
and engine and you build a podcast I
think it's lights out man I think you
can crush it I uh and what's interesting
is our pods not even big so let's just
say we're between one and three million
downloads depending on uh a combination
of YouTube or not YouTube I uh and it's
it's not YouTube first so like we we our
faces aren't out there if I'm walking
around a top 10 City so like a New York
down to like a Denver
I will get recognized maybe once a day
and that is a very small audience that
is not if there's 350 million people in
America and we only reach one or three
million of them a month and I get
recognized probably five times a week
um or like yesterday I went to Lululemon
and I had to give her my email and my
email is my name and I told her my name
and she looked up and she goes away from
my first million are you staying for my
I was like yeah what's going on but she
goes I thought I recognized your voice
and uh like that happens all the time
and that's one of my biggest surprises
is that we get recognized on such a
small audience and the people are like
pumped they're excited which I would be
too if I you know like Brennan's shop is
someone I really admire and you probably
have no idea who that is and he's not
like famous A-list famous if I saw him I
would be like dude can I get a picture
you know what I mean it is so that's the
interesting thing about podcasts do you
get like Instagram models that slide
into your DMs so that's funny uh I
surveyed my Twitter audience and I said
what gender are you and it was 93 dudes
and if you go to our meetups we had a
meet up in New York
um we had uh 1500 people RSVP I don't
know how many people actually showed up
but let's just say 800 or 500 people
showed up I'm pretty sure it was 90 men
as well so my stuff is mostly all men
and also on all of my social media
profiles there's a picture of me and my
wife is as either the main picture or
the cover picture so most everyone I
always talk about her so most everyone
knows that I'm married
um so do I get like women dming me in
the in the sexual sense no but that's
not really like it's happened like maybe
at most once a month but like you have
to remember that a this is like a tech
and business podcast and B I'm like a
Midwestern seven so like you know
dude I'm a Missouri seven and like a New
York six
do you realize that like 99 of our
audience if they had Instagram models
sliding into their DMS once a month
would not be like it's not that much
they'd be like I got Instagram models
standing in my DMs once a month maybe
I'm rich I'm famous well I get and I get
I now how many fake high uh profiles do
I get sliding into my DMs once yeah or
five times a day so yeah so I don't know
how many of these women are actually
real but I would say maybe one time a
month there's someone who like I'll even
I'll be sitting next to Sarah my wife
and I'll be like hey this is crazy check
this out and like we'll laugh about it
uh and I'm like
you know I ain't touching that but just
so you know like this exists I was
talking to someone who was more
conventionally famous than either one of
us and uh
and they were talking about how they get
like real like verified models uh
sliding into their DMS all the time this
person has a girlfriend and uh and is in
a long distance relationship it's very
hard for them they're just like all the
time these people are slapping that's
crazy no I I get like uh I get like the
hand models I don't get the face models
or the body models no I I don't exactly
get that but what happens a lot is if
when it's warm outside I always work out
outside and I'm always shirtless uh
there seems to be a like just an unlucky
pattern of I get recognized shirtless a
fair bit and I always put my shirt on
right when I'm because like me and Sarah
have been on walks where I've been
shirtless and like a guy will come up
with like with his like four-year-old
daughter and say like what's up and I'm
like oh dude I'm totally making this
little girl uncomfortable being this
shirtless dude right here so like that's
our joke is like I try if I'm ever gonna
be shirtless I'll wear like glasses or
something because I don't want to be
like that one time that I see someone
that is like uncomfortable for them uh
but that happens all the time it
happened yesterday yeah you're so you're
saying your body's more famous than your
faces
no I'm saying it's coincidence that I
usually when I'm outside during the day
I'm shirtless and again maybe it's not a
coincidence maybe they're just like and
maybe they don't recognize your face but
they're like that those are sampar's
packs
apps I would and and like I've got like
uh I've got like a New York 7.5 bod so
like it's not always embarrassing but
the other so the other day we released
an episode that was uh about like
Fitness and so people loved it people
loved it yeah people loved it it was a
great episode but Sam
dm'd me and was like hey can we change
my after pick I don't think I look
ripped enough and started sending me
like five to ten shirtless picks it's
like dude if I'm gonna be here why does
my body look best if I'm gonna be
shirtless on the internet like I I would
prefer like the best I hate being the
best like so like that yeah but uh so
anyway that's the update on the Pod do
we want to talk any more about that just
like one other thing I just like a
couple Frameworks I think are
interesting
so
I've been thinking this for a little bit
it's interesting we do interviews and
it's always surprising which episodes
actually pop off like we'll get someone
really really famous and their episode
will do okay
and then we'll get Peter levels or we'll
get darmesh and the episode will go
crazy we'll do super well dude because
we need more unique weird people
sometimes we're Cloud Chasers you need
unique people and it's like when you get
unique people that have a super engaged
audience that want to hear from them but
don't get to hear from them often then
it totally blows up so I've been
thinking about that recently
um
with my pod in terms of what I do so I
could go the route of like
uh doing more episodes like Julius
Caesar like I could do a Charlemagne or
Winston Churchill or Muhammad Ali yeah
bottom line is there's actually a lot of
Muhammad Ali content out there uh and
you could probably
finds stuff that's as good as my podcast
or nearly as good as my podcast out
there
um and so I've pivoted to doing stuff
that's a little more Niche and so I just
did an episode on Brigham Young
who most people don't care about but
some people care about very very
passionately and so it's actually on
track to be my most downloaded episode
and so I'm trying to like adopt that
Peter levels up Peter levels darmesh
like unique episode
uh kind of framework of now I'm starting
to think like okay Brigham Young huge in
the Mormon Community like people want to
hear about that that's going to down
that's going to drive downloads and then
those people are into my audience who
else can I do like who is the greatest
emperor of of
Cambodia you know like
cambodians probably don't get a lot of
podcasts made about their Heroes right
so like can I do that can I drive
something for that audience and then
those people become super okay have you
ever looked up have you ever watched
Bruno Mars YouTube videos no are they
good no so that's my point so a lot like
Bruno Mars is one of those guys who like
everyone knows about but not that many
people seek him out even though he's
pretty amazing and I love his music
videos and I was watching some of them
and they have like one two three even
four I believe billion views Bruno Mars
has four billion views and you and I was
wondering why and I looked it up on
Wikipedia and then I looked at on the
YouTube comments to see if it was like
if I felt like it aligned but basically
Bruno Mars uh his mother is Filipino so
he's part Filipino and the Philippine I
mean how many people live in the
Philippines like you know a ton I think
like hundreds of millions it's not
exactly like a small little country but
in terms of the amount of people who
exist in that country compared to their
cultural relevance on a global scale you
know they're not they're not exactly
represented a ton and so when this
American Filipino guy it's kind of like
Jeremy Lin in the NBA you know there
there's a lot of Chinese but there
weren't a lot of Chinese basketball
players and so when Bruno Mars like got
famous like the Filipinos were like yes
one of us they're killing it and so they
just like get behind that person same
with Bjork from Iceland Iceland like not
exactly incredibly relevant on you know
they don't exactly invent a lot of
things including entertainment that like
it's recognized on a grand scale and
when Bjork like gets a little bit of uh
love from America or Europe they all
pounce on that and they go hell
yeah it's one of us it's like it's like
Nelly in St Louis in St Louis where I'm
from like you know my 65 year old white
dad is like Nellie's the man sir Nelly
like people everyone in St Louis is like
Nellie's just our God he's our mayor we
will do anything for Nelly because he
represented us and we didn't have a lot
of representation St Louis so anyway I
think it's the same way with different
topics where if you find that one or two
things that it it's okay if it's not
that many people but they're like
passionate about it and they can rally
behind it and they're like finally
something for us that just makes it so
much so much easier to get popular it's
a little bit of the Amazon strategy
right like so Amazon is the store for
everything online right but it didn't
start out that way it was a bookstore
and then it was a DVD store and then it
was a dog toy store and it's like
actually just a collection of niches
that all got bundled and that I think
that works for Content as well you can
just go out and collect niches and then
it becomes like a big broad audience
even though you don't start that way
yeah and so right at this point we're a
little bit more broad we're still not
that broad but we're more Broad and like
we make Dumber jokes and we talk about
Kim Kardashian every once in a while now
and uh but before it was just like this
dude's making five grand a month on the
internet you know what I'm saying
um all right is that the pod that's a
pod
[Music]
foreign